council's long-term plan is the 10-year  vision for the city  it's the projects that we want to  undertake and it's also how we're going  to fund them  it's something that the rate payers help  inform and it's also something that they  hold us  accountable for our long-term plan is  reviewed  consulted on with our community and then  updated every three years  this october we're asking you to tell us  what's most  important for the city for the next 10  years this will help us form  our draft long-term plan which will  include information  and options available to us we will then  consult with you again  before adopting the long-term plan in  2021  you